capacité
je l'ai vu j'y suis allé
c'est organique c'est des rochers
c'est virevoltant c'est vivant
c'est électrique c'est sauvage je l'ai vu j'y
suis allé c'est
rugissant c'est furieux
ça grandit c'est farfelu
c'est électrique c'est sauvage des
centaines et des milliers et des millions  et
des milliards de milliards et des
milliards de milliards de novas
supernovas hypernovas rayons
gamma
c'est des rayons X en expansion exploser s'écraser
et danser fracasser et souffler
et tout se
passe au-dessus de nos têtes tout se passe au-
dessus de nos têtes tout
se passe au-dessus de nos têtes
j'ai vu  ça j'y suis allé
c'est violent c'est c'est
rapide c'est
brillant c'est
électrique c'est sauvage je l'
ai vu j'y ai été
formidable c'est profond c'est
époustouflant c'est rude c'est
électrique c'est sauvage des
centaines et des milliers et des millions et des
milliards de trillions et des zillions de milliards x
-ray
tout est en expansion explosant écrasant
et dansant fracassant et soufflant
et tout se passe au-dessus de nos têtes
tout se passe sur des rayons
X rayons X
rayons X
ceci